when you last watched the twilight
franchise did you get a nagging feeling
that those fierce females reminded you
of other characters
you'll soon know why once you've seen
disney princesses recreated as all the
key cullens volturi shapeshifters and
regular old humans
lucky for them the royal squad didn't
need to get bitten by a vampire to
transform
we let our super talented artists do all
the hard work instead
transforming your favorite disney
princesses into their look-a-like
twilight ladies
let the magic commence
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
talk about a totally vampirific
transformation
which disney princess twilight
recreation do you love the most
would you like to see disney princes
recreated as the male characters from
the movies
which prince looks most like edward be
sure to let us know in the comment
section below
thanks for watching
[Music]
you